e aí galera que assistir ao canal tudo
bom você estamos aqui para mais um
bate-papo inédito comigo e você só nós
dois aqui esse canal esses dias passados
aí que passaram anteriormente decidido a
gravação desse vídeo alguns dias atrás a
assistir um filme de terror eu falar pra
vocês que eu não tenho medo de filme de
terror ou assistir filmes de terror eu
fique rna galera gritando eu vim da casa
as pessoas não consigo achar nada de
terror no filme de terror só que o
problema não é enquanto assiste filme
tenho um problema é depois do fim de ter
você já percebeu que make voluntários e
depois que você assistir o filme de
terror você começa a querer se proteger
mãe só não parece que o envolve um manto
protetor da capa da invisibilidade de
harry potter ninguém está vendo mais e
às vezes fico pensando que a gente cobre
o pé é a chapa principal um corpo é o
peixe e cobra o pé para que um monstro
não venha puxar o seu pé não fico
pensando que diabo monte vai sair lá da
monstruosidade dele a puxar o seu pé com
o rei na vez um bem muito e sempre tem
aquela parte que você está assistindo e
você fica a ganhar fica tentando falar
com as pessoas da televisão não até
parece que a pessoa e eu e vai não vai
eu vi que você já imagina se a gente
pudesse opinar não estivesse assistindo
um filme o meu deus do céu vai matar com
a faca vai cortar o meu corpo está
pensando meu deus isso aí
oi
isso pra esquerda corre corre corre
corre do capitão buraco entra entra no
buraco e isso fecha fecha fica aí vai
ficar isso ok
a irmã pronto passou salvei o meu deus
não abre não tem de quê não acontecer né
qualquer coisa a gente combina uma coisa
e depois ok tá certo vai cabo foi o
crédito
salvei
ela foi dormir bem mas sabe o que eu
acho mais interessante mesmo é a questão
do medo triplicadas depois que você
assistiu de deus tem sabor de neto
chamou de mel
minha vitória hoje 30 na bolsa de meio
com deus me dê deus me leva através de
deus espírito santo
eita mãe da moça idéias como essas
coisas direito
[Música]
o pai também foi um terror é porque à
noite um cabo para explodir tem estão 48
horas só de noite e eu acho massa também
tem uma coisa que eu acho muito macio de
filme de terror é que villa não sente
fome milan kaká eo vilão sempre chega
primeiro do que a pessoa e o que é
engraçado é o que a pessoa está correndo
sem bolt asafa powell e juntos 21 diz
120 km por hora eu levantasse o vilão
saber levar alento corrente não queriam
ainda que tudo vira a esquina que está o
vilão para a dança é é o que eu falo
veloz roda nem o fará um filme de terror
no bairro seu mocinha ou vilã outra
coisa acho muito mais que esse time
inteiro é que você fica impressionado
sempre acham que toda todo lugar tem
alguém observando neste momento que eu
sei que tá tá mais está aqui atrás de
mim a minha exorcista o absoluto alice
no país das maravilhas também também que
toda atrás de mim observando que me
pegar né meu deus eles acham que eu não
vi que eles correm mas é isso aí galera
quero saber de você o que você acha
interessante o estranho engraçado
esquisito um filme de terror toca a esse
comentário você gostou de se ver não
esquece da aplicada não gostei que me
ajuda muito centrada escrito esse canal
que inscrever se eu tiver virou sem
saber viu asafa powell usain bolt
queniano e é isso aí falou
[Música]